yeah don't wear out all your clapping on
Charlie I
mean
uh in
addition uh well we have first of all
Greg AEL a director
and and a g Jane sitting next him runs
insurance
and moving then to this back of this
first section if if each of the
directors there would remain standing
till we finish we'll uh we'll go
alphabetically down the line and we've
got Howard
Buffett we
have Susan
Buffett
Steve Steve
Burke Ken
Chanel Chris
Davis Sue Decker Charlotte Gman Tom
Murphy
Jr Ron Olen Wally whites and Merl
Whitmer
[Applause]
okay uh there are two people I would
like to thank and then we'll get on to
the uh brief description of the results
of the uh first
quarter uh first of all
I'd like to thank Melissa Shapiro who
put this whole event together that you
can't imagine the work that goes into
it she just reported to me that we set a
new record for seiz candy I think they
brought on six tons and they will sell
out uh and one thing I do want to
mention we have only one book at the
bookstore at The Bookworm this this uh
year normally we have about 25 but we
have p po poor Charlie's Almanac fourth
edition and I think we sold about 2400
of them yesterday and uh uh that will be
the only book next next year we'll go
back to having our usual selection uh
but we thought we would uh just turn it
over to Charlie this year and then uh I
would like to introduce one further
person and that's uh the person who put
that movie together and you can't
imagine the amount of work it is because
for example on those scenes that we've
used from the
past uh if they
involved uh Hollywood stars or burgus
people we needed to get permission all
over again to show it because we're we
told them originally we would only show
it uh within the confines of our uh
Auditorium here and uh of course it went
out on CNBC and and you just can't
imagine how much effort but also the the
the great cooperation we got from uh
all those Desperate Housewives and Jamie
Lee and with the Desperate Housewives we
we had to get Disney's okay and and that
was easy to get but running down five
Desperate
Housewives that one came on came in
toward the end but we that that the job
of putting this together has been
handled by the same fellow that handles
us been doing these for years and years
and years and years and I just would
appreciate it if you could just put the
spotlight on Brad Underwood for just
minute okay we um we put out some
results uh for the first quarter this
morning at 7 o'clock our time and uh uh
some uh few sharpy analysts and and uh
press people already picked up one or
two items from it which I'm sure we'll
get some questions on later but if we
could start out with slide number one
which is should be showing now you'll
see that that in the first
quarter the way and we talk about
operating earnings at Berkshire we we
explained that many times is why we
think these figures that we give you are
the most descriptive of what's really
going on in the business and and take
out the wild swings in the market that
uh that otherwise just uh you know and
that was reporting big earnings one
quarter and big losses another quarter
we we pay no attention to those at
Berkshire but you will see that that we
had uh a better than average quarter uh
and a g
Jane wants me to point out to everyone
that you cannot take the insurance
earnings of the first quarter and
multiply by four uh it it it just
doesn't work that way in insurance and
uh while we insure storms around the
world the major storms for example that
would affect our earnings with would be
probably number one would be some
something uh that went along the that
came in at the wrong place from our
standpoint and then just kept going up
the east coast and that's
our that's our number one risk as we
evaluate things but we're in all kinds
of risks there can be an earthquake
tomorrow there can be an earthquake 10
years from now and then they're you know
we we're in that sort of business but
the first quarter does
does um hit the uh should be our best
quarter certainly shouldn't be our worst
quarter the most likely quarter to be
the worst quarter is the third quarter
but anything can happen insurance but
fortunately nothing much happened in
Insurance during the first quarter so we
had much improved earnings in in
Insurance underwriting and then our
investment income is was almost bound to
well it was almost certain to incre and
I said that in the annual report because
yields are so much higher than they were
uh last year and we have uh a lot of
fixed short short-term Investments that
are very responsive to the changes in
interest rates so that figure is up
substantially and I can predict that
that one will be up uh for the year uh
uh we've got got more money to invest as
we'll get to in a minute and uh that's
fairly predictable uh so that number
will be up when you get into the into
the railroad the railroad
earnings uh we down modestly and and uh
but
uh
we should not immediately but we we we
should be earning somewhat more money
than we are earning under present
traffic conditions and then traffic
conditions can also hit the uh earning
uh it's a potential earnings of the
railroad and uh if you want every
Wednesday uh you can get car loadings
from the previous week and I'll reg you
a little deranged if you do get them but
I get them every week uh they're
available and you'll see that car
loadings have been running uh for the
industry have been running down modestly
and uh
uh these earnings
are were as is expected but but we
should earn somewhat more money than
that on the equivalent amount of car
loadings and uh uh uh we in the Energy
company uh we had
better earnings but our earnings were
distorted well they they were affected
by conditions that I wrote about in the
annual report and we'll undoubtedly
discuss more this morning but uh a uh
off a low base of last year they were up
somewhat and uh so you get uh down to
the final figure and uh 11.2
billion
is uh
it's quite an improvement from last year
but we would expect our earnings should
go up modestly from year to year because
after all we're we're retaining like 37
billion last year of earnings so if we
put 37 billion more you left it with us
uh we should do something that's
satisfactory and the goal of Berkshire
economic goal is to increase the
operating earnings and increase the
shares outstanding it's that simple to
describe it's not quite so simple to
pull off necessarily but that that
that's what we're attempting to do and
if we'll turn to slide two
please I've got the history and I I just
picked the pre
pandemic uh uh year of when we hit 24
billion and then we fell off in the
first
year of the pandemic and then as you see
we've moved up from 27 to 30 to 37
billion and uh interesting thing about
these earnings is they're after
depreciation and amortization and taxes
and all that sort of thing
so you can figure that essentially uh
berer has a little over hundred million
doar per day including weekends and
holidays
coming in to uh
deploy and uh We've set out many times
when we're attempting to we're
attempting to deploy that money but but
we have that responsibility and uh um
sometimes if you'll turn to the next
page uh well you'll see how that's built
up the shareholders Equity so that
Berkshire uh had at March 31st 500
74 billion and uh
uh through retaining earnings and we've
been retaining
earnings ever since we took control of
birkshire out the way
except one
day as I
remember I think it was maybe 1968 or n
i i the directors declared a 10 cent a
share dividend and I I think I must have
been in the restroom or something at the
time uh uh so uh if you leave out that
period of Madness uh we've been
retaining our we've been saving your
money putting it to work and sometimes
sometimes we've done things that were
big mistakes and but but never we never
get close to fatal mistakes and every
now and then we do something that really
works and as Charlie pointed out in my
past you know it's
really there's probably been a
half a dozen
to a dozen over 57 or 58 or whatever it
would be uh really important big
decisions and there's been nothing close
to
fatal uh so that continues to be the
guideline and uh uh we have accumulated
571 billion and I I couldn't help uh but
look at who's second and uh uh JP Morgan
at 327 billion at year end and and
they're up to 338 I believe on end of
the quarter and but they pay significant
dividends they repurchase shares they've
got a business that earns better Returns
on
Equity but they they don't plow it and
they shouldn't uh they don't plow it
back exactly like we have and it this
does show what can be done
uh really without any Miracles if you if
you save
money uh over time and uh we have a
group of shareholders we had a group of
Partners originally Charlie and I did
that wanted to save money and uh left
their money with like in that film you
just saw you saw Eddie and Dorothy Davis
and uh the Davis family and the children
and the
grandchildren uh periodically did some
other things with the money but they
also basically left it with us and and
we were a savings vehicle and uh they
were able to do live very well but they
weren't they weren't trying to to live
like the uh kings and queens of earlier
capitalism and used to build the houses
and in uh uh New England and you know
have a servant but standing behind
everybody eating and all that sort of
things so we've had very few what I
would call look at
me uh type people that are attracted
there's nothing wrong with it but but uh
but they just go someplace else and uh
and they are
spending uh uh sort of unbelievable sums
after a while by the standards of the
past and our people nobody we've have
nobody that's a that's a miser or a
hoarder or anything like that in our
group they live very well but the math
of compounding and a long long
Runway uh have done wonders and we will
talk a little
later uh uh right before lunch we'll
we'll give an illustration of that of
what can be done with that sort of
philosophy
uh
so uh our cash and treasury bills were
182 billion at the quarter and and I
think it's a fair assumption uh that
they prob probably about 200
billion at the uh end of
the uh this
quarter um we'd love to spend it but we
won't spend it unless we think we're
doing something that
has very little risk and can make us a
lot of money and and uh uh and our stock
is at a level
where it's it's adds slightly to the
value when we buy in shares but we would
we would
really uh buy it in in a big way except
you can't buy it in in a big way because
people don't want to sell it in a big
way uh but other certain market
conditions we could deploy quite a bit
of money in in in uh repurchases and as
you'll see on the final
slide uh uh we have bought it in the
last five years uh we can't buy them
like a great many other companies
because it just doesn't doesn't trade
that way the volume isn't the same
because we have investors and we and the
investors the the people in this room
really
uh they don't think about selling they
probably I would hope many of you don't
even check the price daily uh or weekly
uh you know it uh the people who check
the price daily have not made the money
that the people have forgotten about it
basically have over the years uh um it
uh and that's sort of the story of
Berkshire will try to increase operating
earnings
and uh we will try
to uh reduce shares when it makes sense
to do so and we will hope for an
occasional big
opportunity and we're quite satisfied
with the position we're in uh so with
that background I think we'll turn it
over
to uh Becky quick and we will
alternate qu questions between Becky and
uh those of you in the audience and uh
uh Becky you want to start with the
first question sure thanks Warren um
let's start just given what you
mentioned there was some news that came
out in the 10 Q this morning it shows
that Burkshire sold another 115 million
shares of Apple in this last quarter
that's berkshire's largest holding and I
I think in that vein we'll start with a
question from Sherman lamb he is a
27-year-old Berkshire hathway class B
shareholder uh from Malaysia and he asks
um last year you mentioned Coca-Cola and
American Express being Burkes two long
duration partial ownership positions and
you spent some time talking about the
virt virtues of both these wonderful
businesses in your recent shareholder
letter I noticed that you have excluded
Apple from this group of businesses have
you or your investment manager views of
the economics of Apple's business or its
attractiveness as an investment changed
since Berkshire first invested in
2016 uh no I would the but we have so
shares and uh I would say that at the
end of the year I would think it
extremely likely that that uh that uh
Apple is the largest common stock
holding we have now one interesting
thing is that uh Charlie and
I uh looked at Common Stocks or
marketable equities or the things that
people love to look at as being uh
businesses and so when
we when we own a Dairy Queen or we own
whatever it may be uh we look at that as
a business and when we look own
Coca-Cola uh or American Express or
apple we look at that as a business now
we can
buy really wonderful compan compies in
the market as businesses we can't buy
all of them I mean all of the their
shares we can't buy 90% or 80% or
anything like that but when we look at
Coca-Cola and American Express and apple
we look at them as businesses now
there's differences in tax factors
there's difference in manage of
responsibility a whole bunch of things
but in terms of deploying your
money
uh we always look at every stock as a
business and we don't we have no way no
attempt made to predict markets we have
no attempt made to uh uh pick stocks I
went through many many years uh doing
the wrong thing uh I got interested in
stocks very early and I was fascinated
by them and uh and I wasn't wasting my
time cuz I was reading every book
possible and everything else but finally
I picked up a copy of the intelligent
investor in Lincoln and and there was a
few sentences in there that that said
much more eloquently than I can say it
but if you look at stocks as a business
and treat the market as something that's
doesn't tell you isn't there to instruct
you but it's there to serve you uh
you'll
do a lot better over time
uh then if you try to take charts and
listen to people talk about moving
averages and look at the that
pronouncements and all of that sort of
thing and so that made a lot of sense to
me that and the way
I'm we have been allowed to deploy it
Charlie and I talked about this of
course
constantly uh it's changed over the
years as the amount of capital we have
in the has changed done all of that but
the the basic principle was was laid out
by Ben
Graham in that book which uh I picked up
for a couple of dollars and uh and which
basically said to me you've been wasting
your time now but maybe you can use what
you've learned or been reading about and
put it to better use and then Charlie
came along and told me how to put it to
even better use and that's sort of the
uh story of why we own American Express
us which is a wonderful business we own
Coca-Cola which is a wonderful business
and we own Apple which is an even better
business uh but uh uh and we will
own let something really extraordinary
happens we we will own apple on American
Express in
Coca-Cola uh uh when Greg takes over
this place and and
uh uh it's
it it it's such a simple approach that
it's almost deceptive you most things if
you keep working harder and harder at it
you know you learn a little more math or
you learn a little more physics but
Investments you don't really have to do
that you really have to have your your
mindset properly so so we will we will
end up andless something dramatically
happens that really changes Capital
allocation uh strategy uh uh we we will
uh we will have apple as our largest
investment uh but I don't mind at all
under current conditions building
uh the uh cash position I think uh when
I look at the alternative of what's
available in the equity markets and I
look at the composition of what's going
on in the world uh uh we find it quite
attractive and one one thing that may
surprise you but uh uh
we almost everybody I know pays a lot
more
attention
uh to not paying taxes uh uh and I think
they should uh uh uh it we we we we
don't mind paying taxes at
Burkshire and we are paying a 21%
federal rate let the gains were taking
in in uh apple and
uh that rate was 35% not that long ago
and it's been 52% in the in the past uh
when I've been operating and uh
it uh the government owns
the federal government owns a
part of the earnings of the business we
make they don't own the assets but they
own a percentage of the
earnings and uh uh they can change that
percentage any year and the percentage
that they've decreed currently is 21%
and I would say with the present fiscal
policies uh I think that
something has to give and I think that
the higher taxes are are quite likely
and
uh the government wants to take a
greater share of your income or mine or
burchers uh they can do it and uh uh
they may decide that someday they don't
want the fiscal deficit to be this large
because that has some important
consequences and they may not want to
decrease spending a lot and they may
decide they'll take a larger percentage
of what we earn and we'll pay it and we
always hope at Berkshire to pay
substantial federal income taxes we
think it's appropriate that a company a
country that's been as has been as
generous to our
owners it's it's been the place I was Lu
Berkshire was lucky was here and uh uh
if we if we send in a check like we did
last year we sent in over5 billion to
the US federal government and if 800
other companies had done the same thing
no other person in the United States
would have had to pay a dime of federal
taxes whether income taxes
no social security taxes no estate taxes
no it's up and down the line now that's
that's
uh I would I would like
to I I hope things develop well enough
with burshire that we we say we're in
the 800 club and uh and maybe even move
up a few notches uh it doesn't bother me
in the least uh to write that check and
uh I really hope with the all of
America's done for all of you shouldn't
bother you that we do it and if if I'm
doing it at 21% this year and we're
doing it at a higher percentage later on
I don't think you'll actually mind the
the fact that uh we sold a little apple
this
year okay let's go to section
one hi Mr buffer this is Matthew Li from
China Hong Kong I'm running my last
listing company called fop fop and we
are so grateful that you learn from you
and you really Inspire us my questions
is besides the electrical Car Company
B under what circumstances you will
reinvest and reconsider to invest Hong
Kong and China company thank you yeah
well uh our primary
investments will always be in the United
States uh we do think
it now the companies we invest in the
United States American Express does
business around the world and no company
hardly does business around the world
like Coca-Cola I mean
they're they are the
preferred uh soft
drink you know something maybe like 100
70 or 180 out of 200 company 200
countries those are rough approximations
from few years back probably but
but that degree of
acceptance worldwide
is
uh I think it's almost unmatched I can't
really think of any company that has it
American
Express uh has a
position uh and
the uh credit card bill which I think is
extremely strong and um uh and part of
that was one of the direct part of the
reasons for that is one of the directors
that introduced a few few minutes ago
Ken chanol but it it is it is
strengthened dramatically over the last
20 years for a lot of reasons uh so we
will the the byd
investment was
a
uh and well we we made we made the
commitment in Japan which I did 5 years
ago and and that was just overwhelmingly
was
compelling uh it was extraordinarily
compelling and we put we bought it as
fast as we could and we spent a year and
you know we got a few perc of our Assets
in five very big companies but that's
the problem of being our size but you
won't find us
making a lot of
Investments uh outside the United States
although we're participating through
these other companies in the world
economy uh but I
understand uh the United States rules
weaknesses strengths whatever it may
be I I don't I don't have the same
feeling for for uh economies generally
out around the world I don't I don't
pick up on other cultures extremely well
and and lucky thing is I don't have to
because you know I don't live in some
tiny little country that has no uh just
doesn't have a big economy but I'm in an
economy already that has uh you know
after starting out with a half a percent
of the world's population has ended up
with well over 20% of the world's output
in in an amazingly short period of time
so so I we will we will be American
oriented uh uh I mean if if we do
something really big it's extremely
likely to be in the United States uh
Charlie uh uh in all those years there's
only two times he told me that you know
this one is really you know he he would
he would always go along with me and you
know and say well when I was suggesting
something say well this is really not
that great but but it's probably the
best you'll come up with so I'll go
along with the
idea and uh but Charlie Charlie twice
has pounded the table with me and just
said you know
uh uh by Bye by and uh byd was one of
them and and Costco was the other and uh
we bought a certain amount of Costco we
bought quite a bit of byd but but uh but
looking
back
uh I he already was as aggressive but I
should have been more aggressive uh in
in Costco it wasn't fatal that we we
weren't but but he was
right big time in both companies and uh
uh I will I'm aware of what goes on in
most markets
but I think it's unlikely that that we
make
any large
commitments uh in almost any country you
can name although you know we don't rule
it out entirely and uh I feel extremely
good about our Japanese position and
we'll have
that um I don't know how many
years Greg will be sitting with that at
some point and and we couldn't be
happier with that but you really have to
we really have a different
Outlook in looking at at at well we look
at your money which we couldn't bear to
lose and we feel that we we're bar less
likely to make any truly major mistakes
in the United States than in many other
countries okay
Becky uh this next question comes from
Stanley Holmes who is a Berkshire
shareholder from Salt Lake City he asks
in his 2024 annual letter to
shareholders chairman Buffett noted the
severe earnings disappointment
experienced at Berkshire hathway energy
last year and expressed concern about
earnings and asset values in the utility
industry recognizing that investors are
worried about climate change related
expenses and that new uncertainties
Cloud the regulatory environment the
chairman suggested that some
jurisdictions may adopt the Public Power
model there are now signs that policy
makers in Utah stating uh citing state
sovereignity may already be poised to
move in that direction the Utah
legislature recently mandated the
state's right to serve as sole purchaser
of energy from an instate power plant
and under some some circumstances
purchase the power plant before it can
be retired the state utility regulator
will be legally bound to prioritize
public purchases of power and Facilities
that could include assets owned by
Berkshire haway energy specific cor
utility Rocky Mountain Power will
Burkshire through bhe continue to invest
resources in jurisdictions where
corporate assets may be subject to
confiscatory State policies and actions
and how is Berkshire energy working with
officials in Utah to minimize potential
corporate losses if and when State
control is asserted over its electrical
utility sector yeah I will Greg join
with me in the answer on this but I
would say our our feeling is that Utah
is
actually very likely to treat us fairly
whether the action is in in granting
appropriate rates that give us the
return we expected generally expected in
in terms of Our Own own properties or if
they decide for some reason to go to
Public Power I think they would
compensate us fairly uh
uh in the 1930s George Norris the
senator from Nebraska just turned
Nebraska into a public power State and
uh our experience in
Iowa uh would indicate that that uh free
enterprise has its role and that uh uh
we can run
a
a privately owned uh utility
company uh that will be more efficient
for society than at least in Most states
people can do uh with Public Power uh
but what has happened is
that there's going to be enormous amount
money enormous amount of money uh spent
on power uh and we've been we are if
you're going to do it with with uh uh
private owners there's nobody better
situated than
Berkshire to
satisfy
the the portion but a large portion of
the need leads of the country and and we
will do it at at at a rate of return
that
is is not you know it's not designed to
make us make us rich or anything like
that it's it's it's a sensible rate of
return
but uh we won't do it if we think we're
not going to get any return it' be kind
of crazy and
uh uh we've seen actions in a few states
where
uh
there some of the costs associated with
climate change are not being regarded as
as uh cost of the utility shouldn't
incur well believe me if it was publicly
owned they would have incurred it too
but but we will will the wood Society
tells us and we have got the money and
we've got we've have the knowledge to
participate big in something that is
enormously important for the country but
we're not going to do we're not going to
we're not going to throw good money
after after bad in the field I don't
worry
about my understanding is and Greg can
elaborate on this now immediately uh but
I don't regard Utah as uh being
unfriendly uh to the idea of utilities
being treated fairily
Charlie Charlie I'm so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
used I had actually checked myself a
couple times already
but I'll slip I'll slip
again that's a a great honor word um
yeah when we well when you touched on it
initially in your letter uh relative to
the
the challenges in the industry and then
you've just alluded to the significant
investment that has to go into the
energy industry the utility sector for
for many years to come and and I think
if we start there if I think of our
different utilities and will definitely
come to to Utah and Pacific Corp but if
you look at the underlying demand that
is building in each of those utilities
and the amount of dollars that are going
to have to go in to meet that demand
it's absolutely incredible so when you
raised it in your letter it's a really
important issue we have to have a
regulatory compact that works between if
it's a public utility it has to work in
in concert with the the state Utah being
an example or It ultimately becomes
potentially a public power entity so if
just to just to set the the frame a
little bit if I think of Iowa which you
meant mentioned and the underlying we've
made substantial Investments there it's
been very consistent with both the the
public policy that the state and
legislator wanted and they enacted very
specific laws to encourage that but that
utility is more than a hundred years old
right now and if we look at the
demand that's in place for Mid-American
Iowa Iowa utility over the next say into
the mid 2030
um associated with AI and the data
centers that that demand doubles in that
short period of time and that happen and
it took a hundred years plus to get
where we are today and now it's going to
double and for and that will require
substantial amounts of capital from the
from Mid-American and its shareholders
and how that will function is if we have
a proper regulatory compact in place
which which you've highlighted if we
then go to say
Nevada where we we own two utilities
there uh and and cover the lon share in
Nevada if you go over a similar time
frame and you look at the underlying
demand in in that
utility uh and say go into the later
2030s it
triples the the underlying demand and
billions and billions of dollars have to
be put in our rate base will literally
go from um uh it's not a modest level
now uh but you're talking uh probably an
incremental 6 to 10 billion at least of
rate base going into that type of entity
which requires um again alignment with
the the state and their policies and a
proper recovery of our underlying both
capital and uh a return on Capital so
when we come of the wildfires that's
been a substantial challenge because
it's the first time there's been a lot
of discussion
around one of our utilities one
experienced significant losses
associated with the the the wildfires
what portion of those costs will be
recovered and that's really the the
dialogue we're in and does that properly
properly work uh when I think of the
wildfires
were there's been many claims and a a
recent additional claim last week for
$30 billion doar and it's we we don't
take that lightly but it is an
incremental claim to an already existing
lawsuit that's in place and when I think
of Pacific Corp we're we're in a place
where um first and
foremost all the litigation will be
challenged because the basis for it um
um
uh uh at least we believe there's places
where it's un unfounded and we'll
continue to challenge it uh and it will
take many years to be resolved as as
Warren highlighted in the letter but if
you think of Pacific Corp uh and the
litigation there um number
one how we how we think and operate
those assets have to change because
we've had a regul we we have worked with
the states across all our states for
many years years with the fundamental
goal to be to keep the power
on and our our teams and our employees
worked incredibly hard to keep the power
on day in day out through storms
unfortunately through the 2020 fires the
instincts were not to turn off the power
the Instinct was to keep the power on to
keep
hospitals uh fire stations responding am
it's not in their mind to or at least
culture it wasn't in our minds to De
energize so the first thing we had to do
was step back and say we've got to
fundamentally change the culture not
just at Pacific courp but across all our
utilities the first thing we have to
recognize is that there's now going to
be uh situations where we prioritize
de-energizing the assets and that's
completely different than we've how
we've operated those assets as I've
highlighted for 100 plus years so we we
start with the culture we had to change
that the second thing is we've now
changed our operating systems so that we
can turn off the power very quickly if
there's a fire that's encroaching we
will turn off our systems now and we'll
go the minute the the the conditions are
safe again we'll re-energize it but
we've had to do that and then the uh
third thing is continuing to invest in a
way that uh allows us to try to minimize
the risk of the fire but when you get
back to Utah and Pacific Corp the
challenge we do have is within Pacific
Corp as we go through both litigation
and through continuing to operate that
entity it generates a certain amount of
of capital and profits that will remain
in that entity and be reinvested back
into that business but but
fundamentally as we go
forward we need both legislative and
Regulatory
reform across the Pacific Corp States if
we're if we're going to deploy
incremental Capital make incremental
contributions into that business as
Warren said we don't want to uh throw
good Capital after um bad Capital so
we'll be very disciplined there but the
reality is there are opportunities to
both solve the the legislative and
Regulatory Solutions and the and the
best example we actually have and I
think it's the gold standard across the
country is Utah so as Warren touched on
it's a it's a state we're we're happy
we're investing in it is part of Pacific
corpse so there's a certain amount of
balance there as to how we do it but in
the last legislative session that that
existed Utah actually passed a bill that
does a couple very very important things
one it caps non-economic damages on
Wildfire
claims so if you go back to the
wildfires we have in
Oregon um and the claims you're hearing
filed
for there's economic damages associated
with them and and those harms should
receive the economic damages associated
with that but
unfortunately and even though there's
legislature and in case law in Oregon
that says um wildfire non-economic
damages should not be awarded there's
very substantial non-economic damages
being awarded there Utah took a very
proactive position to say we will cap
those non-economic damages and it
creates an environment again it's back
to that is there an environment where
you want to invest in yes and then and
then incrementally they've created a
very substantial IAL fund it's a
literally called the Wildfire fund for
for fires in Utah that will help
facilitate both liquidity and the
ability to resolve the situation so Utah
We Believe including the legislation
that um a lot of other things came out
of it is the actual gold standard as we
go forward so very important issue for
Berkshire haway
energy uh but at the same time it is a
Pacific or
issue the the risk of regulatory
compacts not being respected a much
broader one that will always evaluate
and be careful how we deploy our Capital
but um both Pacific orp will manage
through it and I see other very good and
significant opportunities in Pacific
Corp uh I mean in uh Berkshire hathway
energy the the return on the return on
Equity investment it's been
been promulgated and been achieved over
the years has been particularly in
recent years well below the return on
Equity that has been achieved by
American industry generally and so
uh the whether whether you earn X or X
plus a half a percent or x minus a half
a percent that differs by state and some
states are more attra active than other
but whether you earn X or go broke is
not an equation that works and uh you
know we're we won't we won't put our
shareholders um money they didn't give
it to us to lose it all and uh uh we
might like it if it's better when it's X
plus a half a per and x minus a half a
percent but the electric utility
industry will never be as good as uh I
mean just remotely as good as you know
the kind of businesses we own in other
Arenas I mean you look at the return on
tangible Equity at at Coca-Cola or
American Express
or and to really top it off Apple uh it
it's just it's you know it's it's just a
whole different game but in utilities
the trade has been and the the the
compact has been that you get a a modest
return and uh uh climate change comes
along and it causes way more
fires uh that's just the cost of doing
business and doesn't mean that we can't
do things to
mitigate uh fires in the future and you
can make different policies on when you
turn off the lights but somebody's going
to do somebody's going to put
up many many hundred hundred of billions
maybe in the trillions and climate
change enters into that and uh it can be
done through Public Power or it can be
done through private Enterprise to quite
a degree uh and we would be certainly
good for 100 billion or more but we're
not going to throw good money after
bad okay let's do um station
for hi I'm Joe visiting from San
Francisco how do you think about the
role of technological advances
especially generative AI on more
traditional Industries thank you yeah I
made a mistake in calling on four but
I'll get back to two later on the uh the
uh I don't know anything about about
AI uh
but I do I do have I don't that doesn't
mean I deny its existence or importance
or anything of the sort and and last
year I said you know that the we let a
genie out of the bottle when we when we
developed nuclear weapons and that Genie
has been doing some terrible things
lately and the power of that Genie is
would you know scares the hell out of me
and under that I don't know only way to
get the genie back in the bottle and AI
is somewhat similar it it's out it's
part way out of the bottle and and uh
it's enormously important and it's going
to be done by somebody so uh we may wish
we'd never seen that Genie or may do
wonderful things and I'm certainly not
the person that can evaluate that and I
probably wouldn't have been the person
that could have evaluated during World
War Two whether we tested the 20 th000
ton a bomb that we felt was absolutely
necessary for the for the United States
and would actually save lives in the
long run but where we also had Edmund
teller I think it was it was on a
parallel with Einstein in terms of
saying you may with this test ignite the
atmosphere in such a way that
Civilization doesn't continue and we
decided to let the genie out of the
bottle and it accomplished the immediate
objective but whether whether it's going
to change the future Society we will
find out later now
ai I had one
experience that does make me a little
nervous and I'll just explain it that
very very
recently uh fairly recently I uh I saw a
uh an image in front of my eyes on the
screen and it was it was me and it was
my
voice and wearing the kind of clothes I
wear
and my wife or my daughter wouldn't have
been able to detect any difference and I
was delivering a message that no way
came from me so it when you think of the
potential for scamming
people if you
can
reproduce images that I can't even tell
let's say I need money you know I'm you
know it's your daughter I've just had a
had a uh car crash I need throw $50,000
wired I mean scamming has always been
part of the American scene uh but this
would make me
if I was interested in investing and
scamming it's going to be the growth
industry of all time and it's enabled in
a way I now maybe you know obviously AI
has potential for good things too but I
don't know how you based on the one I
saw recently uh I practically would send
send money to myself over in some crazy
country uh it so uh I don't have any
advice on all the world handles it
because I don't think think we we know
how to handle what we did with the
nuclear uh Genie but I do
think as someone who doesn't understand
a damn thing about it that it
is it has enormous potential for good
and enormous potential for harm and I
just don't know how that plays
out uh i' I'd like to mention to Becky
that that a je will will not be been the
the uh afternoon uh session so if you
could focus on any if there are
Insurance questions you want to ask that
be a good one yeah this next question is
for both Warren and AIT um it's from Ben
null who's a Minneapolis shareholder
who's been a shareholder since 1995 and
he says in an interview this past year
Todd col said that in first meeting you
in 2010 he told you Geico is better at
marketing and branding but Progressive
is a data company and data is going to
win in the long run but it appears you
did not prioritize data analytics at
Geico until a decade later when you made
Todd
CEO as business units like Geico age and
need new strategic direct Direction I
wonder if berkshire's hands-off
management approach is a source of
vulnerability will you please review
your thinking on changes made at Geico
and explain how Berkshire is structured
to react if the Berkshire CEO sees that
a business unit is strategically off
track and a g I hope you will continue
to update us on yours and Todd's
progress at remedying the data analytics
shortcomings at
Geico would you like to yeah uh as
Warren has pointed out in the past one
of
the one of the drawbacks that Geico is
faced with it hasn't been doing as good
job as matching rate with risk and
segmenting and pricing product based on
the risk characteristics uh this has
been a disadvantage at Kao for a few
years now we are trying to still play
catchup technology is something that is
unfortunately a bottleneck But there
again we are making progress uh and
equally importantly we have hired people
who are much better than what they the
they inherited in terms of data
analytics and pricing and slicing data
so yes I recognize we still behind we're
taking steps to bridge the gap and
hopefully by the certainly by the end of
25 we should be able to be uh along with
the best of players when it comes to
data analytics whether it's pricing
whether it's claims or any other factor
that drives the economics of the
insurance
business I would add that equating rate
with risk obviously
is is important in every line of
insurance business I mean that's what
you're involved with us deciding whether
a given rate offers us the chance of the
probability that we will make a little
money on it and that sometimes we're
only risking losing a little and
sometimes we're risking losing huge
amounts but but but Geo and and
Progressive has done a better job that
in that recently but but our fundamental
Advantage at Geico of course is that we
have lower costs than virtually anybody
and that cost Advantage has been
dramatic we've driven our underwriting
expense ratio below 10% and there's
there well there's just very very very
few companies that can compete with that
so so it
isn't it's not it's not in the least a
survival question and it isn't even
exactly a profitability thing but you
know we would rather have x% of the mark
and a half of x% but but uh we
roughly uh I think in the month of March
we we were just uh we didn't we didn't
lose policy holders and we got 16
million or whatever it is of them and
and we've got the lowest cost operations
so it's it's it's it's not a threat it's
not remotely a threat to survival it's
not a throat to it's not a threat to to
even profitability but on the other hand
we would like to be growing with with
something that is is the best model
around in the insurance business uh uh
of delivering at a low cost and we now
have a recognition that we didn't have
back when Leo Goodwin started at 1936
but the same principle that worked then
is that if you can offer somebody a good
product cheaper than the other guy and
and everybody PR has to buy it and it's
a big business you know it's very
attractive to be and and Geico is a very
attractive business and has got its
lowest cost thing and it does have to do
a better job of matching rate to risk
but but our low costs have have massed
the fact that for a while that we could
we could
do uh without progressing as much as we
should have been the matching of R to
risk and now Todd has been working
intensively at that and he's made a lot
of progress but there's there's still
work to be do be done but in the
meantime we're not going to shrink and
uh uh and we're going to we should make
uh better underrunning profits than most
companies in the a Insurance
business okay I'm going to back up and
go to uh I think I left station two out
of it earlier
so do we have somebody there yeah good
morning my name is Sebastian Zar I'm
from Munich Germany but I have way is a
very respective this company in Germany
and my question is who are your most
advisor today is it Ted and Todd is it
Greg and AIT is it your wife your
children and what do you value about
them thank you well it depends whether
they're advising me on money or on other
things I I trust my children and my wife
totally but that doesn't mean I ask them
what stars to
why the uh uh but the know I I
was in terms of managing
money uh there wasn't anybody better in
the world to talk to for you know many
many decades than Charlie and uh that
doesn't mean I didn't talk to other
people but if I didn't think I could do
it myself I wouldn't have done it I mean
it uh uh so I to some extent I talk to
myself uh on investments and and and I I
think my children have gotten a whole
lot wiser over the years and uh uh so I
listen them to on a lot of things uh
I'll listen to my my daughter on who to
vote for locally cuz she knows a lot
more about that than I do uh and I'll
I'll listen to my wife on a lot of
things and I won't get into
details so it it uh it is it is
important if you don't live a life where
you surround yourself and limit yourself
to people you
trust uh it won't be much fun I mean I
literally have been in the position ever
since I was in my
20s of being able
to have people I trusted around me and
I've made mistakes occasionally but and
but they filter out over time you learn
and uh uh when I found Charlotte for
example and in all kinds of matters not
just
investment uh you know I knew I'd have
somebody that that uh well I'll put it
this way you can think about this
Charlie and all the years we worked
together not only never
once lied to me ever but he didn't even
shap things so that he told half lies or
quarter lies to sort of Stack the the
deck in the direction he wanted to go he
was he
absolutely he considered a to of utmost
importance that he never lied now that
occasionally got him in trouble at
dinner parties or something if he he
said to the woman I really prefer the
way you used to do your hair the way
that somebody over across the room does
I mean he was but in terms of having a
partner I I I simply cannot think of a
conversation I ever had with Charlie
that in the least he misled me or shaped
it his way or anything of the sort so
when you get that in your life uh you
know you cherish those people and you
sort of forget about the
rest
[Applause]
okay okay uh this question is for a uh
comes from Mayer
baruka climate change seems to be
impacting the insurance industry heavily
with major players pulling out of
markets like California because of
wildfire and flooding risks combined
with payouts increasing how does Mr
Janes see this risk expanding to other
regions and how has the thesis on
insurance Investments changed because of
it
yeah climate change climate risk is
certainly a factor that is become has
come into focus in a very very big way
more recently now the one thing that
mitigates the problem for us especially
in some of the reur ins operations we
are in is our contractual liabilities
are limited to a year in most cases so
as a result of which at the end of a
year we get the opportunity to reprise
including the decision to get out of the
business all together if we don't like
the pricing in the business but the fact
that we are making bets that tie us down
to one year at a time certainly makes it
possible for us to stay in the business
longer term than we might have otherwise
because of climate change clearly prices
need to go up it is difficult to be very
scientific about how much the prices
need to go up they need to go up a lot
and we keep increasing prices and hope
we stay above the ahead of the curve but
that doesn't happen in noral cases The
Regulators don't make it any easier by
tying our feet to the ground and making
it difficult for us to withdraw from
certain territories or to make uh
dramatic changes in in the pricing of
certain products uh as a result of which
a number of insurance carriers including
ourselves have decided to not write
business in certain States I think The
Regulators are getting a little more
realistic about the and they're waking
up to the fact that the reg that the
insurance carriers need to make some
kind of a return a decent return for us
to keep deploying our Capital it's a
constant battle back and forth It's been
against the capital providers these last
few years
but I think we're coming back into
balance if you look at the results that
have been recently announced by the
insurance carriers everyone's now making
record profits OB obviously that will
not last but certainly for the next
several months I think the insurance
industry in spite of climate change
spite of
increased risk of fires and flooding
it's going to be an okay place to be
in yeah climate climate
change increases risks you know it it in
the end it's it makes our business
bigger over time is but not if we if we
misprice them we'll also go broke but uh
but we do it one year at a time
overwhelmingly and uh and I would say
this I would I would rather have a Jeet
assessing this than any thousand under
writers or or Insurance managers in the
world I mean it the
the factors aren't you know well we'll
take Atlantic hurricanes that which
would be our probably our biggest risk
you know
the there's no question that you can
measure the temper temperature of the
water in the Atlantic and and uh you
know what more water does the Hurricanes
but you don't know what
necessarily whether that's good or bad
because it may cause them to turn f
you know it may it may change the path
as well as the intensity and frequency
of of of of losses uh but we'll we'll
write it one year at a time and we'll
have Vegeta underwriting it and you know
we don't have to tell you what's going
to happen five years from now or 10
years from now and uh uh people who
don't have sort
of analytical Insurance Minds that
comment on this subject
really don't expand our knowledge it's
it it's uh we get a lot of letters from
people that I'm sure have good IQs but
they they don't really know they've they
don't understand the insurance business
and uh and they're not wrong I don't
think in my mind about climate
change but uh if there was no risk
there'd be no insurance business and and
we're in the business of evaluating it
and we do it one year at a time and
there's some exceptions where you can't
do it where your your uh decisions
extend for a long time in the future and
uh we try to avoid those but
again
uh you don't need a thousand people
analyzing water currents and you need
you need one very very very smart guy
and we've got
him okay yeah the the only thing I'd add
is that climate change much like
inflation Done Right can be a friend of
the risk
Bearer and it has been for
us if you look at Geico it had
175,000 policies roughly in 1950 and it
was getting roughly 40 bucks a car so
that was 7 m ion of of
volume and you know now we have uh we're
getting over
$2,000 well all the advances in
technology and everything like that if
if we had been wetted to some formula
what we did with $40 we'd have had a
terrible business but but in effect by
making the cars much safer they've also
made them much more expensive to repair
and a whole bunch of things have
happened including inflation so now we
have a $40 billion Bill business from
something that was 7 million uh back
when I uh called on it so if if we'd
operated in a non-inflationary world Geo
would not be a a $40 billion
company okay we're we're now finally
coordinated to we station three I I
believe
hello hi everyone I were I'm Liam I'm 27
from Newark Ontario Canada I got invest
birkshire thanks to my dad who brought
me down to this meeting I'm so excited
to be here most 27 year-olds had Idols
who are rappers but instead my Idols are
Warren Charlie who we will miss forever
and also your cousin Jimmy who
unfortunately had to go this year too
it's been a tough year as a Canadian
similar with Greg I always wonder about
our Canadian economy and what you think
about the Canadian economy we got some
Beatdown Bank stocks right now and I
don't know what your opinions on are on
these and I also wonder at in your 90s
if the rumors are true and you're still
able to eat McDonald's I like Fast Moon
myself but I always wonder at 93 he's
still able to eat those and enjoy the
coca-c cola thanks Warren okay well
we've got a Canadian here so we'll let
him answer uh first part and uh and if
you if you if you watch me you'll see
what I I like to eat I
mean but go to it Greg okay um yeah well
we're we we are fortunate to have a
number of operations up in Canada um it
goes across many of our operating
entities and then as Warren touched on
all the businesses that we have a piece
of that we're invested in are are up in
Canada so the presence is significant
we're we're we're always looking at
making incremental Investments there
because it's a it's an environment we're
very comfortable with Warren touched on
understanding the US environment
business environment and and I would put
Canada equally in that uh bucket that we
understand it and would be comfortable
and I I would say the economy moves very
closely to the to the US so the result
results we're seeing out of our various
businesses that report both the US and
Canadian operations aren't aren't
drastically different um and and there's
a few that we're on the energy side for
example we make very substantial
Investments up there in in Alberta but
again it's very consistent with how that
economy is growing and I would see it
being very consistent with what we see
here warrn anything to yeah no we we we
in canadi
when it obviously there aren't as many
big companies up there as there are in
the United States but but when we get a
I got one from Canada just the other day
that I sent over to Greg too that that
when when we see anything that's
suggesting an IDE idea that's of a size
would interest here and meets other
requirements uh we don't have any
hesitancy about uh putting
big money in in in in in Canada that uh
and there are things we actually can do
fairly well that uh uh our candidate
could you know benefit from from
berkshire's participation we did it some
years ago not that many years ago but
but uh there was a financial institution
up there and and uh uh they had a
problem and and they had as I remember
30 plus you know various other people
that were kicking it around and
meanwhile the place was getting close to
the edge for not a fundamental problem
and uh Ted wler from our office went up
there I heard about it on a Monday or
something and Ted wler went up there and
we offered a solution in a couple of
days to something that that was getting
close to the Brinks so it it we do not
feel uncomfortable in any way shape or
form uh putting our money into Canada in
fact we're actually uh we're actually
looking at one thing now uh and but you
know they they still have to meet our
standards on terms of what we get for
our money but they but they don't have a
they don't have a mental we don't have
any mental blocks about that country and
of course there's a lot of countries we
don't understand at all so so Canada it
it's it's terrific when you've got um a
major economy not the size of the US but
a major economy that that you absolutely
you you feel confident about operating
there okay
mecky Warren you just uh said that you'd
rather have a g running risk assessment
at the insurance operations than any
other thousand insurance adjusters in
the world so I'd like to follow up with
a question that came in from Mark
Blackley in Tulsa Oklahoma he said
Warren for years you have spoken about
the incredible impact a Jeet has had on
Berkshire you've often joked if you and
a Jeet are in a sinking boat and we can
only save one of you swim for swim to a
g while we often discuss plans for the
next CEO of birkshire little is
mentioned on who will one day replace a
g how should we think about the future
of the birkshire insurance operations
given how challenging it may be to find
another AIT and uh like to hear ait's
thought on thoughts on this as well well
I would say we won't find another AET
but fortunately he's a good bit younger
than I am so I hope you have to worry a
little bit about me first before we
start working about the
je uh uh
it we won't find another Jeep but we
have an
operation that he has created
and
that at least part of it it's there
certain parts of it that are almost
impossible for competitors to imitate
and and if I was in their shoes I
wouldn't I wouldn't try and imitate them
uh and so we've
institutionalized some of our
advantages but a jate is
well he all his presence allowed us to
do it uh and he did it uh but now
we've we've created a
structure that uh didn't exist when he
came in 1986 nothing close to it existed
with us or with anybody else and uh
insurance is the most important
business at burshire it it uh
uh marketable Securities are important
but uh they're not in the class exactly
as as our insurance business uh uh and
uh a
g we we won't have the same business if
a g isn't running it but we'll have a
very good business and again that thanks
to a g you know I'd been in the business
when he came in
1986 you know I first went to Geico in
1950 we first bought National Indemnity
in
1957 and it was something that we' made
quite a b bit of money in the stocks of
of insurance companies but uh
uh we needed we needed an je
unfortunately he came into the office on
a Saturday and he was
tired of working at something where he
really
didn't it just in challenges is
intellect and uh I said well we got a
lot of challenges so you know you know
nobody's perfect so so you've never seen
an insurance policy own an insurance
stock but here are the keys and that's
worked out very well
well thank you very much Warren thank
thank you very much everyone but the
fact of the matter is nobody is
irreplaceable and we have Tim Cook here
in the audience I believe who has proved
that and yeah has set an example for a
lot of people who
follow that's a great observation I now
having said that I will also add that
our board is conscious of the succession
issue not only at Warren's level but
also at my level and every year they
have me sitting in front of them
answering questions and having me share
my ideas with them in terms of what
would happen to the operations if I get
hit by a truck
uh we go through the various operations
we have I review with them a short list
of people I think ought to be candidates
for replacing me and in addition to that
I go a step further and identify
particular individual as the person I
would hand over the keys to if something
were to happen to me obviously that
could subject to change but we take this
issue fairly seriously and I think at
the end of the day as as Tim Cook has
proved to us it'll be the biggest
nonissue of The Day the Earth will keep
still keep revolving around the axis
okay yeah we know what we we what we
know what we will will do we know it's a
good answer but we know it isn't it
isn't we won't have another
AG uh station
five hi my name is and Andre ncas and
I'm wondering if you had one more day
with Charlie what would you do with him
[Applause]
well it's kind of interesting because in
effect I did have one more day I mean it
wasn't a full day or anything but uh but
he uh
uh
we we
always uh
lived uh in a way where we were happy
with what we were doing every day I mean
Charlie Charlie
liked
learning he liked as I mentioned in the
movie he
liked wide variety of things so he was
much broader than I was but I didn't
have any great desire to be as broad as
he was and he didn't have any great
desire to be as as narrow as but we had
a lot of fun doing anything and um you
know we played golf together we played
tennis together we we did everything
together and and uh and this you may
find kind of interesting we we had as
much fun perhaps even more to some
extent with things that failed because
then we really had to work and work our
way out of them and and in a sense
there's more there's more fun having
having somebody that's uh your partner
in in digging your way out of a fo
Foxhole when there is just sitting there
and and watching an idea that you got 10
years ago just continually produce more
and more profit so it it it wasn't
uh you know he really he really fooled
me though he went to to 99.9 years I
mean it if You' pick two guys you know
he never he he publicly said he never
did it a day of exercise except where it
was required when he was in the Army he
never did a day of voluntary exercise he
never thought about what he ate uh you
know it it it uh
uh you know we started every day and
Charlie had he was interested in more
things than I was but uh we never had
any
doubts about the other person period and
uh uh so if I had another day with them
we'd probably done the same thing we
were doing the earlier days but
we and we wouldn't have wanted to know
that we only had one
day that there's a great advantage in in
uh not
knowing where you're going to what what
day you're going to die that uh uh and
Charlie always said you know that uh
just me where I'm going to die so I'll
never go there
well
uh uh it uh the truth is you know he
went everywhere with his mind and
uh and therefore he was not only
interested in the world at 99 but the
world was interested in him it's it's
remarkable uh you know they
he he I would I I told him to in the
last few years I never seen anybody that
was peing you know in 99 and
and and and uh where the world wanted to
come and see him I mean they actually
wanted to go out to 351 North June
Street and whether it was well I could
name a whole bunch of names but just
I'll start with Elon musker but good on
the list and they all wanted to meet
Charlie and Charlie was
happy to talk with them and I the only
the only uh uh person I could think of
otherwise was the dolly Lama I don't
know that they had a lot else in
common but but uh it was he he he lived
his life the way he wanted to and uh he
got to say what he wanted to
say he like I loved having a Podium and
and again I can't remember any time that
he was mad at me or I was mad at him it
just didn't happen uh uh and calling him
was fun back when longdistance rates
were high and and the
and we didn't talk as often as the years
and recent years is we used to be on
daily uh for long
periods and and we did keep learning and
we like learning together but uh uh you
know
I
that we tended to be a little smarter
because when as the years went by cuz we
had mistakes and we had other things
that where we learned something and and
the fact that he and I were on the same
wavelength in that respect meant that uh
that the world was still a very
interesting place to us when he got to
be 99 and I got to be 93 so I don't have
a perfect answer for you there but I can
tell you the ingredients that would
going to
uh uh sometimes people would say to me
or at one of these meetings you know if
you could only me have lunch with one
person that uh lived over the last 2,000
or so years you know who would you want
to have it with Charlie says I've
already met all of them you know because
he he he read all the books I mean he he
he and he eliminated all the trouble of
going to restaurants to meet him or
anything like that he just went through
a book and he met Ben Franklin and he he
really uh he was remarkable he but uh he
said he really had no one else to meet
because he he'd read all their stuff and
he liked Ben frankl's stuff better than
he liked mine but but uh but with Ben
Franklin he just had to read about it
didn't have to they didn't have to go
have lunch with him or anything of the
sort uh but it's an interesting question
what you should probably ask yourself is
that who do you
feel that uh you'd want to start
spending the last day of your life with
and uh and then figure out a way to
start meeting him or tomorrow and uh and
meet them as often as you can CU why
wait a little last day at uh and don't
bother with the
others okay
Becky uh this question comes from Carol
deand and Switzerland uh in Europe and
this is for both Mr Buffett and Mr Jane
as political instability in the world is
growing with a rise in the number of
armed conflicts and trade tension there
is also increasing risk of cyber attacks
what are your views on cyber security
Insurance asking this question in
general for retail small businesses and
large companies including critical key
infrastructure such as power plants
Harbors airports nuclear plants Etc do
you see potential for profit making in
cyber security insurances and what are
the key
challenges uh okay let me start cyber
secure cyber insurance is become a very
fashionable product these days uh over
these last few years it is at least a
1010 billion market right now globally
and profitability is also being fairly
High I think profitability is at least
20% of the total premium uh has ended up
as profit in in the pockets of the
insurance be bearers now having said
that we at Burkshire tend to be very
very careful when it comes to taking on
Cyber Insurance
liabilities um for the part of actually
for two reasons one is it's very
difficult to know what is
the Quantum of losses that can be
subject to a sing Single occurrence and
the aggre ation potential of cyber
losses especially if
some Cloud operation comes to a
standstill you know that aggregation
potential can be huge and not being able
to have a worst case gap on it is what
scares
us secondly it's also very difficult to
have some sense of what the what we call
loss cost of the cost of good sold could
potentially be it's not just for a
single loss but for losses across over
time they have been fairly well
contained out of 100 cents of the dollar
of the premium losses over the last four
or five years I think have not been
beyond 40 cents on the dollar leaving a
decent profit margin but having said
that there's not enough data to be able
to hang your hat on and say what your
true loss cost is so in our insurance
operations I have told the people
running the operations is I've
discouraged them from writing cyber
insurance to the extent they need to
write it so as to satisfy certain client
needs I have told them no matter how
much you charge you should tell yourself
that each time you write a cyber
insurance policy you're losing money we
can argue about how much money you're
losing but the mindset should be you're
not making money on it you're losing
money and then we should go from there
so it is it's projected to be a huge
business my guess is at some point it
might become a huge business but it
might be associated with huge losses and
our Ro is to sort of stay away from it
right now until we can have access to
some meaningful data and hang a hat on
data well you've just made You' just
heard why aeta is invaluable
because that
uh
uh when you insure something you really
want to think of what how much can you
lose and the
question I remember the first time it
was happened I think in the 1968 when
there were the riots in various
cities because I think Bob I think it
was the Bobby Kennedy death that set it
off for the Martin Luther King death I'm
not sure which one but in any event when
you write a
policy you have a limit in that
policy but the question is is what is
one
event so if if uh uh if
somebody is assassinated in some town
and that causes losses of thousands of
businesses all over the country if
you've written all those thousands of
policies you have one event or do you
have a thousand
events and there's no place where that
kind of a dilemma enters into more than
cyber because if you think about it if
uh you know let's say you're
writing $10 million of limit per per
risk andde that's fine and you if you
lose 10 million you know for some event
you can take it but the problem is if
that one event turns out to affect a
thousand policies and somehow they're
all linked together in some
way uh and the course decide that
way uh you've written something
that in no way we're getting the proper
price for and and could break the
company and I will tell you that most
people want to be in anything that's
fashionable when they write insurance
and cyber an easy issue you can write a
lot of it and uh the agents like it you
know they're getting the commission on
every policy they write and you've got
to have somebody in charge of things
that understands that you may get an
aggregation of risk that you never
dreamt of and may be worse than some
earthquake happening someplace just
because you have a whole bunch of
policies with a million dollar limit and
I would say that uh human nature is such
that that most insurance companies will
get very excited and their agents will
get very excited and it's very
fashionable it's kind of
interesting and uh it's would say it may
be R
poison okay well that's cheerful here we
go to station
six good morning this question is for
waren buffet and great able my name is
Maria PES I am a retire from Las Vegas
Nevada I am here today as a member of
chispa Nevada a group developed Latin
leaders for the environment of justices
I am Al I am almost here representating
Mary Latin families in Nevada who are
struggling to pay their utility bills
and one access to Affordable clean
electricity I want to add today why is
NB energy with which is owned by the
burshire haway building new gas plants
instead of investing in solar energy
with Nevada one and this sunniest state
in the
country can I expect to see future
leadership take dangerous investments in
the fossils l
more
seriously thank you and thank you Maria
uh Greg you want sure um thank you so as
we touched on with Envy energy even
earlier there's um a lot going on there
and I when I think of uh there's no
question solar is a a great opportunity
for NV Energy and we continue
to um utilize that as a resource
continue to invest in it uh in that
utility and and the other utility we
have in Nevada we're also in a point
where when you think of a transition
that's going on within the energy sector
we are transitioning from carbon
resources to renewable resources as was
noted but it it it will not occur
overnight that transition will take many
years and as we use be it renewable
resources such as solar or wind they are
in intermittent and we do try to combine
it with batteries but it do at this
point in time we cannot transition
completely away from the carbon
resources so if I think of Nevada in the
in the next two years our last two coal
units are well actually in the next year
our last two coal units will retire but
we are replacing them with uh a new gas
unit which is is truly needed to make
sure that system remains uh reliable and
available to our to our customers and
that's and that's done in conjunction
with our with the state um
representatives and our Regulatory
Agencies to make sure we can serve those
customers every day and every minute we
have great examples in Iowa where at
times 100% of our energy comes from wind
and we're and we're thrilled with that
and I believe we hit that for example on
Earth Day uh every we had enough wind
that we could meet the demand of that
state but the next day if the wind's not
blowing we need our gas resources our
gas plants to to fill that Gap and
really that's the situation we still
have in in Nevada so we'll continue the
transition to renewable resources be It
Solar in Nevada and wind and other areas
combined with battery iies but for the
foreseeable future we do see gas being a
very important resource to help maintain
reliability and meet meet our customer
customer needs and and to meet it in an
affordable way is also an important uh
piece of that so thank you for your
comments all right yeah
we in in a fact we we've got the capital
to do whatever makes the most sense in a
place like Nevada and the Nebraska the
Nevada I don't know each each state
calls their ruling commission something
different but they probably call the
Public Service Commission or something
like and they they're making the
decision as to what they
think can and should be done uh in terms
of getting from
where a vastly
complicated utility business
moves towards something different
without messing things up in the
meantime and and uh you know having the
lights go off and they they I think they
would probably agree with you very much
Maria that they what they what they want
to get but they can't they can't do it
tomorrow you know you know because the
inter intermittent problems and uh their
job is to make sure the lights stay on
and their job is also to move
uh toward better
sources um but solar will never be the
only source of uh of electricity because
it uh uh well Greg may know more about
this but barring some real breakthroughs
and storage and that sort of thing right
yeah yeah generally a battery right now
to do it in a economical way is is a 4H
hour battery
and and when you think of the time
without um the the sun being available
that's a that's a b that's a challenge
now there there's a lot of technology
advancements and that's stretching out
and you throw dollars at a lot of things
you can accomplish things but the r is
that's there's a there's a careful
balance of of the reliability and also
balancing as you as it was noted the
rates do matter and and how much
customers are paying so delicate balance
of both delivering reliability but doing
it in an affordable way yeah my friend
Bill Gates he's working on shortening up
that or lengthening the time the battery
works on and so you got some very smart
people working on but it isn't something
that you actually do overnight and and
uh I can understand why people want it
that overnight but it it is going to
take a lot of money it's going to take a
lot of good ideas and smart people like
Bill and Greg not me I don't I don't
understand why the damn lights go on
when I even turn the switch but those
those Fells really do know and there's
plenty of them working on it and we got
plenty of money to implement it but
there
are there are certain things that
uh that just take a certain amount of
uh time my daughter hates it when I use
this example but uh it's really true
that you can't create a baby uh in one
month by getting nine women pregnant I
mean that you know you may want you may
want a baby but so there are certain
laws of nature that you have to work
with Okay
Becky uh this question comes from Rich
McClosky in dun Eden Florida he says
Warren and a would you let us know what
you think about the car and property
insurance situation in Florida as a
resident both seem out of control
control since the Florida Market seems
to be so mismanaged is this an
opportunity for
Berkshire yeah the Florida Market both
for auto insurance and for homeowners
insurance has had a few tough years uh
the two problems we face in Florida and
all the risk bearers face in Florida one
is the lawyers and the amount of
corruption that takes place in the
Florida Market is keep skyrocketing
making it difficult for us to price
price the product and make a profit and
secondly the amount of activity in terms
of storms both the frequency and the
severity is also so severe
that the losses in Florida tend to make
it very difficult for a risk Bearer to
make money having said that we've had a
we've fortunately had a very good run at
Florida last year we increased our
exposure in Florida as we talked about
last year and fortunately nothing bad
happened so a lot of our premiums that
were in the Top Line flew straight to
the bottom line Florida is a large
Market Florida is a market that's
subsidized by the rest of the country I
don't think
those that's going to stand the test of
time the Florida Market the legislators
are trying to improve it they have
passed law that is bringing down the
amount of fraud that takes place in
Florida and I hope Florida will be a
fairly buoyant Insurance Market because
at the end of the day they do believe in
the free market more than some of the
other states that have a insurance
crisis like California and New York so
yes Florida has a problem prices will go
up fairly substantially but at the end
of the day I think we'll achieve a
degree of balance so that the risk
bearers can make a decent profit and
will be deploying Capital out
there okay station seven please
hi Warren um my name is Christine hone
Garcia and I'm from aora Hills
California thank you for being an
excellent teacher and imparting your
wisdom to us throughout the
years what advice would you like to
share today that you believe everyone
needs to
hear well too bad you didn't that he
added that what what the rest of us
would like to
hear the uh no
they oh I would say that if if I had one
piece of advice I would
try well and you're lucky you live in
this country because it just to start
with because you've got opportunities
here that wouldn't exist in much of the
world uh
but I would like I I would like you
the really sort of use Charlie's advice
of the thinking how you like
your obituary to read and then uh uh
start selecting the educational pass the
Social pass you know
whatever na that your P particular
situation in terms of
associating and
perhaps uh certainly in my day I would
have been marrying the person that
would best help you do that well Charlie
would say you were offering some similar
benefit to the
partner and
uh uh you know the the opportunity in
this country is you know just basically
Limitless that uh
when you think of going back not that
many centuries you know if you were
going to be a Shepherd or something like
that you 100 years from now you're
you're you know your your grandson was a
grand daughter was going to be a
Shepherd I mean nothing nothing really
happened and what has happened in the
last 200 years with the combination of
the Industrial Revolution and but
whether it's science or education or
health or you you name it we are so
lucky to be
born uh when we were the people in this
room and and many of us we're lucky
enough to be born in United States as
well uh that uh you know
you you've had the you're entering the
best world that's ever
existed and you want to find the people
to share it with and the activities to
participate
in uh that fit you and if you get
lucky uh like Charlie and I did you find
things that interest you young but if
you don't find them right away you keep
looking and uh uh I always tell students
that take the job that you I mean find
the job that you want would like to have
if you didn't need a job and sometimes
you can find that very early and
sometimes sometimes you go through
various experiences but don't forget
what you're trying actually are trying
to do and there's no place to do it like
this country and find the person that
you like to share your life with uh in
many cases and and and you know
sometimes you get lucky and do that
early and uh and sometimes you make
mistakes and uh
but uh I would
I would try to in a very very general
way I would try to figure out how you'd
want to look back on your life and think
about yourself and and uh and start the
day to go on the path that leads to to
that goal and expect expect some some uh
difficulties along the way but if you're
if you're thinking that way you you're
more likely to get there
Becky uh this question comes from as
Axel mayor seek in hurg
Germany um what has changed for
berkshire's operating CEOs since Greg
Abel and AET Jane became vice chairman
for example can and do the operating
CEOs still reach out to Warren Buffett
directly well let's
uh might the answer might surprise you
but they they
overwhelmingly uh the operating
Executives uh well they they prefer to
talk to to Gregor to to a je and uh that
didn't that's understandable because uh
I don't really do much and I don't
operate at the same level of efficiency
that I would have 30 years ago or 40
years ago I don't know the managers as
well as I would have when we were
smaller and when I could get more
accomplished in the day than I can now
and you've got when you've got somebody
like Greg and a Jeet uh you know why
subtle for me I me basically so it's
it's it's worked out extremely
well uh
uh
and
uh I I almost can't imagine anything
working better because uh
Greg in the year
accomplishes I mean he sees more of them
understands more about their problems
you know can give them suggestions he's
got incredible amounts of energy and
and
uh no body has more wisdom than a Jeep
about insurance and uh they've got
access in the insurance to him now they
had it before we stuck some of those
titles on in Insurance whereas with
gregy much expanded things when when
when he
became uh the vice chairman in charge of
of really everything except insurance
so he
is if you P our
managers uh that fall under his
jurisdiction which would be a lot of
them uh uh
they they
would much preferred
unless like a few they weren't paying as
much attention to their business and I
wouldn't do anything about it but but
Greg would and uh and they still like it
when he does it he can deliver he can he
can deliver news very well to to people
who uh you know there's some there'll be
some people if you have if you have 20
children and you're very rich you'll
have some that will be go-getters anyway
and you'll have some that that uh won't
and uh we are a very very rich company
and uh we
don't
uh we we haven't had a history
of being very tough on on people that uh
coasted and we've had some that would do
that and Greg will do something about it
and Charlie and I wouldn't have uh not
because we didn't know it should be done
but because we were doing so well
ourselves and everything it just
wasn't we didn't we wouldn't make the
effort we didn't want to change our
lives that way plus we slowed down in
various ways physically and everything
so so I would I would uh
I would say that
uh the number
of calls I
get for managers is is essentially
awfully close to zero and Greg is
handling those you know I don't I don't
know quite how he does it but but uh but
uh we've got the right person I can tell
you that and with the G he he he does
less physical moving and and the
insurance people are more used to
working with the Jeep obviously over the
years so uh I wouldn't say
that changing the title would be Chang
as much there because he was in charge
of insurance anyway and uh so that's uh
you know you can you can go to a
business school and and they can give
you way better answers the I've just
given you but but that's the way we do
it at Berkshire she raised his hand yeah
uh if I can add a comment from my
perspective the transition has worked
out very very well but I think the
credit really goes to how Warren has
handled the situation and what I mean by
that is after the transation was
announced and a lot of the operating
managers used to be they were used to
calling Warren directly on some issue or
the other
when they after the transation when they
would continue to do so Warren would
very skillfully in his in his manner
handle them such that he would not
answer what they were looking for but at
the same time made them feel good and
told them that he sort of enjoyed
hearing from them and talking to them so
as a result of which you know the
transition took place people got the
message they got the message and were
very responsive to it and it's a
non-issue as far as today's
concern I'd probably add
yeah the only thing I would add is we do
have an exceptional set of managers
across both the um uh non-insurance and
insurance and yes Warren made it
incredibly easy but so did they it it
was a very easy transition because they
cared deeply about Berkshire they care
deeply about the culture and they very
much wanted it to be a a success and
we're fortunate to have uh those
managers in insurance and non-insurance
so thank you yeah what what Greg is
talking about is they really wanted more
Direction in in some cases than than I
gave them you know I mean it uh I just
sat there reading the Wall Street
Journal or whatever and uh uh Greg is I
don't you
know there one way or another there are
more than 24 hours in his day you know
and uh I I I just don't know how he
covers the ground he does but but he
knows more about the people
uh
he we got the same feeling in terms of
judging the attractiveness of businesses
and making Capital decisions and that
sort of thing but but he's willing to
work I mean I you know I I I uh you know
and I couldn't get as much done anyway
you know what I could do in in couple of
hours you know may take it hours now it
it it I just don't read as fast and
different things said but uh it it's
working very well and and uh uh this
place if anything happened to me it
would be
working extremely well the next day I
don't get any phone calls you could you
can actually we can we can rig something
up so we got some answering machine that
people think I'm still around you know
or something in
terms so anyway that's that's uh much
much less than you'd learn in business
school but that's the way we do it at
Berkshire okay station
eight dear Warren Greg and Ajit thank
you for having us your teachings have
not only made us better investors but
more importantly better people thank you
for that my name is Rajiv Agarwal and I
am from New Jersey I run an India Focus
fund called DHI India fund my question
is related to India Indian economy and
Indian equities have done quite well in
the last 5 10 20 years it is the fifth
largest economy and will be the third
largest in the next few
years my question is is birkshire
actively looking for opportunities in
the Indian Equity market and what will
allow you to buy anything meaningful
there thank you yeah well it a very good
question and obviously India you know
it's I'm sure there are loads of
opportunities in a place like India and
uh the question is do we have any
advantage in either insights into those
businesses or contexts that will make
possible
some some
transaction that uh might what the
parties in India would particularly want
us to participate uh uh I would say that
that's something that a more
energetic management at at at
Berkshire could pursue uh
because we do have the reputation now
Berkshire is known not like it's known
in the United States but it's known
around the world and and uh you know our
Japanese experience has been fascinating
in that respect uh uh so there may be an
unexplored or uh unattended to
opportunity in that area I'm not the one
to do it um but that may be something
that uh uh in the
future
uh it might be opportunities there there
there there are opportunities the
question is is is does Berkshire have
some kind of advantage in actually
pursuing those opportunities against
particularly against people that are
using other people's money that that
where they get paid based on
asset uh on assets managed or something
of sort I mean there there are plenty of
people in the game who are buying and
running businesses that uh uh do not
really have our philosophy I mean they
uh they uh uh they're going to get rich
no matter what happens and and uh
uh
the their payment may be based on on on
how much they buy rather than what they
buy uh so we'll see how the next
management plays the game out at at
Berkshire and fortunately you don't have
too long to wait on that generally I
feel fine but but but I I uh I know a
little bit about actuarials at tables
and uh uh uh I just um well I would say
this
I I shouldn't be taking on
any fouryear employment contracts like
several people are doing in this world
in an age where you can't be quite that
sure where you're going to be in four
years
okay but you're de you're absolutely
right about about you you have if you
were
energetic had some way
to uh
become
a
a buyer of
a uh or a a a a a party that people
particularly wanted to do business
with
uh Japan was
great and India could be great but India
and Japan are aren't the same I mean I
don't adapt myself terribly well to
different different
cultures uh and some people are really
good at it uh and almost anybody's
better than I am but I stumbled into one
or two but uh that could happen in the
in in in in you know act two of U
Berkshire out the
way
Becky this is a question from Rafael
doino from
Spain Berkshire has grown tremendously
thanks to and among other things its
architect Mr Munger and you its general
contractor we're all tremendously
thankful to you for taking us along the
way we are aware that both of you and
many others have spent an enormous
amount of time ensuring berkshire's
culture provides a solid footing on
which to grow the building you also
currently have a very talented bench of
what we may label as subcontractors in
Mr Abel Mr Jane Mr Colmes and Mr West
however for a long time you've had the
advantage that talented subcontractors
have wanted to work with a once in a
generation architect and general
contractor how do you envision Berkshire
will overcome the loss of set Advantage
when the contractor bench needs to be
renewed again and what are what are
potential renovation Works in this great
building that may necessitate a new
architect yeah well that's a great
question which the Charlie and I
obviously talked a lot about over time
and of course
we uh we will not Ure to the extent it
Remains the sort of entity that it is
will not need to attract people very
often uh it would be absolutely crazy
for anybody for our board of directors
to ever pick anybody to run this
business that thought you should retire
at
65 uh uh it may be that they should
retire the next day you know when you
learn what they're really like managing
something or it may turn that you want
to keep them around so they they really
start aect being affected by old age
which hits different people at different
times but it hits everybody
eventually and so we it's very
likely that if
it's if the directors and it's very
tough because they will be acting
against conventional wisdom which which
is always difficult and uh but I think
we've got the group on that and they
they will not have to make a decision
very often if they if they pick the
right uh CEO that's 99% of the job of
the directors and uh if they the
other 1% is is you do you have a good
method to correct it if youve made a
wrong decision and that's extremely hard
to do uh in in our present system it's
not impossible but uh uh it's just not
something that happens it's too good a
job to be a director to to to try and
throw over somebody at particularly if
you can use the money from
directorships and you
want to be on other boards and
everything we we we do not have a
perfect system in in terms of boards of
directors at all and it's it doesn't
operate at all well I shouldn't say at
all but it doesn't it it it doesn't
operate as as people may think it
generally operates
so we
will you know we've really got the
problem solved for the next 20 years
unless something UNT happens and
something unto happens then then the
directors need to find probably within
our own
organization uh somebody that they've
got confidence in to
maintain the special advantages we have
uh over another 20 years period it's
there's various things that are low
probabilities but you still have to
think about them and uh and we are in
that position now now if you asked
me whether if something happened to Greg
today everybody says don't travel on the
same plane the thing to do is not travel
in the same Auto planes don't go down
that often Autos crash all the time I've
seen all these corporate policies on
that which are kind of crazy when you
think about the real risk but in any
event uh we do
Greg is going to have to tell the
directors
about what if something happened
tomorrow he has to tell the directors
about what should be done if anything
happens to him and uh that's not an easy
thing to do
and
uh uh I don't
have uh well it it will be his decision
and then the directors
really the decide whether he's made the
right one but he will he will make the
right
one uh and what you really have to hope
is that you get lucky on how long
managers stick around I mean you you
might need three in a century and you
might need six or
seven uh but uh
the the the answer is you need a little
luck and you need some break in the
mortality tables but we've we've got an
entity that if you really aspire to be a
certain kind of
manager of a really large entity there's
nothing like it in the world so uh we've
got something to
offer the person who we want to have you
know it's a sort of like Charlie said
about marrying the best person that will
have you well we we have uh
we've got something
that the right person would want to
marry you know basically in terms of
birkshire uh and if we get the wrong
person then the directors have to do
something about it and that probably
won't happen but it's always a
contingency a possibility I should
say greig having been put on the spot
like that
didn't you don't have to name anybody
now but I'm sure the crowd would love it
make news
LLY thing I would add uh Warren is uh
and it's really how the comment started
was around culture um the culture we
have at Berkshire and that being our our
shareholders being our partners and our
managers of our business having that
ownership mentality that's never going
to change and that will attract the
right managers uh at every level so I
think as Warren said we have a very
special uh company in birkshire but it's
that culture that makes it special and
and that's not going to
change
okay station
nine I'm never sure where nine is hi I'm
Sherman lam a Booker shareholder and I
work for a family office in qualo
Malaysia just really happy to see you
Warren and the team and where I come
from you're hero and both you and
Charlie have positively transformed mine
and many many other Malaysians and
Southeast Asians lives not only
financially but also in how we navigate
our lives and relationships thank you
very very very
much well thank thank you thank you that
that that makes us feel
good question is uh what have your teams
great learnings been on business Capital
allocation stock baking and portfolio
allocation uh throughout the co9
pandemic period over the last 5 years
and Warren appreciate it if you can get
your views as well as uh your you
representations on Ted and Todd as well
as directly from Greg and Ajit to on
their respective businesses thank you
yeah I I don't think I want to give
individual appraisals uh uh and but but
uh what really what you're
doing is uh in terms of capital
allocation which is is my job I don't go
out and sell insurance policies or
anything of the sort uh and you
represent a group of shareholders like
we do represent we we are totally clear
on our
mission
and you know it it may be that other
people don't agree with them but I would
say that in a great many places uh you
know I I I I just don't agree with their
mission and
uh you know I would say that for example
that any anybody that wants to return
retire at 65 would be disqualified from
being CEO of Berkshire then they might
get just they might get retired the next
day if they were the wrong person but
that that there's just certain things we
don't want and uh uh
the we're well fixed
now
and that the odds are very
good but far from
certainty that that takes care of the
next 20 years
now
the but you have to provide for the con
gency and and
uh
I there's
several people on the board that know
what I would do on that but it's up to
Greg but Greg and I go at the same time
then then then you'll move into making
another decision and and uh
uh you know there a few people know my
thoughts on that but but but they the
the job of the director just then to
come up with the right CEO and the right
CEO can't make a terrible business great
Tom
Murphy who was the best he was the best
business manager I've ever known and Tom
Murphy you know he said the real key was
buying the right business and now murf
brought a million other attributes to it
after that but you know
it Charlie you know said we we you know
what was this he had a saying on that
but but
basically we could have brought in Tom
Murphy and told him his job was to run
the textile
business and it would have done a little
bit
better but it still would have failed
and and uh one of the reasons I stuck
with the textile business as long as I
did was that I liked Ken Chase so much
and I thought he was a terrific guy and
he was was a very good
manager and if he'd been a jerk you know
we'd have quit the textile business much
faster we'd have been better off but so
so the answer was for him to get in the
in the TV business like murf had done
and AD supported the you know murf murf
figured that out early and he started
with a
pathetic operation which was a VHF in
Aly New York competing against GE and
everything and he was operating out of a
home for retired nuns and he only
painted the side that faded faced the
street he had one car dashing around
town and he called it news truck number
six but from that he
built an incredible company and he built
it because he was the best manager I've
ever met but beyond that he was in a
good business and uh
uh the key will be to have ke will be to
find another Tom Murphy and then hand
him a bunch of good businesses and and
he or she will know what to do with
it now that's not as precise as you
would get
in uh in most companies but you really
can't get more precise than that I mean
you can have committees and management
consultants and everybody but it wasn't
a Management Consultant that hired Tom
Murphy and and I forget whether he was
doing his sales volume was couple th000
a week at first and then soon as he hit
that was his goal got the 2,000 he say
now my goal is 3,000 he kept doing that
and he surpassed all these people like
CBS and ABC that on the had the World by
the tail and uh it was just a wonderful
lesson in life to get just to be able to
view something like that I
learned an awful lot from what he said
to me but I just learned by watching
somebody like him operate I mean it's
it's it's like watching a great golfer a
great tennis player then you got to
learn something about the kind of Swing
you're trying to develop or something
sort so that's that's not a great answer
for you but it's it's uh so far it's
worked and I think it
works I'm very sure it works with Greg
and it's up to people in the future
when you know at uh I'm underground or
wherever they put me
uh to really make a decision every 20
years or something like that on average
it's the right decision but correct that
if it turns out to be the wrong decision
that's what a board of directors is for
and uh and we've got the people on the
board
that really understand that
responsibility they take it
seriously but they don't take themselves
to too
seriously and uh so therefore they
don't they don't want to they don't
necessarily want to do a lot of things
just to look
busy uh they aren't using us as a
stepping stone to get on other
boards but we've got people that that uh
really believe in what we're doing and
uh and the ones that are going to have
to make
this place work and if they got lucky on
Greg's mortality they they can do just
what rep do go to sleep for 20 years or
so and then make another decision and
and uh and Berkshire
has every tool in the world
available to
be what it is now and continue to be
what it is now I mean that we've gotten
from from 20 million of that Worth to
5 70
billion and
uh uh you know
we there aren't as many things to do but
we can do a few big things better than
anybody else can do and there will be
occasional
times when we're the only one willing
to act and those
times we want to be sure that the US
government thinks we're an asset to the
situation and not a liability or a
supplicant you know as the banks were
will say in 2008 and N that they was
they were all tarred with the same brush
but we want to be sure that the brush
that determines our future it uh you
know is not hard and uh and I think
we're in
the I don't think anybody's got a better
position to do it than
Berkshire
Bey uh this questions from Johan Halen
who writes you're sitting on 168 billion
of cash which you told us today is now
more than $182 billion his questions are
one what is Buffett waiting for and two
to why not at least deploy some of
it well I think that's pretty easy to
answer I I I don't think anybody sitting
at this table has has any idea of how to
use it effectively and therefore we
don't we don't use it and we don't use
it now at
5.4% but we wouldn't use it if it if it
was at
1% um
don't tell um the Federal Reserve that
but
but prefer it but the uh
uh we don't we only swing at pitches we
like and U uh if uh anybody tried to
swing at every
pitch uh or felt that because they
hadn't swung in a pitch for two for the
last two pitches they ought to swing a
third one or something like that it it's
just it's
uh there are times and obviously but I
would say this I I would not like to be
running 10 billion now 10 million I
think we could I think Charlie or I
could earn high Returns on because I
think there's there there just a few
things that happen on a very very small
scale but but it it it it uh if we had
billion uh we wouldn't I wouldn't
basically
see and many more opportunities than we
found now it's true that something like
Japan we could have done if the company
had had a 30 or 40 billion and we'd make
we'd have had great Returns on Equity
but if I saw one of those now I'd do it
for Berkshire that uh you know it isn't
like I'm got a hunger strike or
something like that going going on it uh
it's just that they things aren't
attractive and uh and
there's well there certain ways that can
change and we'll see whether they
do okay station
10 Mr Buffett this is an incredible
meeting that you host every year my name
is Shan colie I am a real estate agent
with Burk hathway Home Services in
Arizona and California my mother Cindy
my brother and my two sisters all sell
real estate with birkshire hathway home
services for many years we love being a
part of the birkshire family and along
with the 70,000 other agents that sell
real estate for the company uh Mr
Buffett Home Services of America
recently settled our class action
lawsuit regarding commissions for $250
Million last week uh this is uh this
dollar meants about 100 million more
than Keller Williams
million more than anywhere real estate
which is Better Homes and Gardens in
Coldwell Banker as a realtor with birkar
hathway home services and multiple
markets and a shareholder who's been
coming to this meeting for 15 straight
years uh that's one of the reasons I got
involved with real estate is because of
this meeting what are your thoughts on
buying and selling a home in light of
this re recent settlement and uh I maybe
asked the note to Greg and a Jeet too
would you consider a birkar agent when
buying your next
home well I don't buy him that often as
some people have noted but uh I
certainly would consider him but uh i'
say the probability of that happening is
low but and I I really appreciate uh the
fact you've joined up with us but I'm
going
to in in terms of the uh the uh
settlement I
mean Craig get me informed but I I
turned it over 100% to him but uh so
Greg you want to talk about it
sure so thank you for uh you and your
family for being an agent and working
for our for our company uh Berkshire
outway Home Services I think there's a
few questions in there one there's no
question the industry will go through
some transitions because of that
settlement ours and the every other
major player in the industry settled the
National Association of Realtors settled
for more than 400 million so um
effectively everybody was swept up in in
that uh settlement and it did set the
grounds for the both home services and
for the industry to move
forward the there's a lot of changes
that happen in or are being proposed
associated with that settlement but the
the one thing that I I think you
hopefully would absolutely agree with
that the real estate agent is still an
important part of of these transactions
it's the one time in our lives where we
make these massive uh Investments and
having that counseling guidance is is
critical and that's really what our
business and those other businesses uh
rely on how the commission structures
change and how it's negotiated which is
really what the settlement was it was no
longer that a buyer um uh would
automatically pay a a commission agent
to the to the selling agent that how now
has to be negotiated that'll impact
things but I think the
realators uh will continue to be a very
important part of that and I think Home
Services in the industry will remain
very relevant and then the only thing I
would share with our shareholders on a
broader basis is that obligation resides
with home services and can be met by
Home Services and that was an important
condition because they were also uh
pursuing Berkshire in Brookshire heway
energy and we said you can Pro pursue us
separately but um that settlement will
reside with home services and be an
obligation of that and they decided the
the ultimate settlement and and uh and
we'll go forward from there so waren any
other well yeah I've sold two houses in
the last well the last 93 fraction years
and and I've and I've and I've uh bought
one uh uh that I still have but I
obviously bought the other to it and uh
uh I I have I have not negotiated down
the commission even
though uh the last one sold for 7
million or something like that people do
negotiate down commissions to some
extent but I can tell you I've looked at
the figures and
I I think the system is really worked
out very well they when I when I got out
of school they had you know what they
called fsbo you know with with for sale
by owner and uh so i' I've I've been
involved to some degree in watching the
whole system operate and uh and I know
what our average agent makes I know you
know how long they work on things
sometimes that get don't materialize I
it it it uh I don't think we will end up
with a a
better system and uh but you know it's
up to it's up to Greg and the the people
at home services how we work it through
here but I I I I like our Agency Group
and I uh we've got a very large number
as you of of BR State agents and I've
encouraged us the expansion we've done
in the real estate agent uh real estate
broker business uh you know it was just
one or two operations when we bought
Brookshire halfway energy and we we
really built built up quite a company
and and uh uh I think it's a very
fundamental business you need
help 90% of the people need help you
know in buying them buying a a home or
selling one and uh and I've watched it
operate all my life and been involved
with lots of people who have been in the
business and
uh but there was a decision in court and
I told I told Greg to handle it whatever
would seemed best to him and I'm quite
I'm I'm perfectly happy with the way
we've handled I think I'm surprised that
the the decision but uh but uh it
uh we get surprised in decisions in in
the insurance business lots of times I
mean just just think of the the various
things we faced and
and you know when 9/11 came along you
know we never thought something like
that could happen but it happened and
then we didn't know what was one event
or more events I mean if you if they
close down the New York Stock Exchange
and a bunch of
Brokers well every all kinds of people
lose their jobs and or or lose their
income for a while is that one event or
multiple events well there's all kinds
of things come up in business and and we
just we we we play the play the ball
whereever we find it and uh and uh I was
surprised by the decision was it in
Missouri but uh Miss yes yeah but we've
gotten surprised by some other decisions
and we'll keep doing sensible things as
we move forward Greg do you want
to yeah um no I think the only thing I
would add back maybe to how the model
has changed and he asked one yes we'll
always I can't speak for a Jeep but
we'll always use Home Services agents
but uh it's interesting I have bought a
home abroad because I I lived over in
the United Kingdom uh in Newcastle
running our uh utility over there and it
is a completely different experience to
buy a home outside of the US uh our
agents take great responsibility for the
the whole transaction in the US they put
as Warren said time and capital uh at
risk to ensure the transaction closes
and when you do close it they make sure
what you bought you actually what you
thought you were purchasing you end up
with and and that's not the way it is
always around the world and there are
more affordable models but it's the old
thing you get what you pay for so I I
think our real estate agents still
provide incredible value within our
business and and that as Warren touched
on it it'll it'll survive the the the
form may be a little bit different but
there's no question it'll it'll it'll
continue to
thrive yeah we still we we still will we
want to buy real estate brokerages at
the right price and uh I hope we're
bigger in the industry 10 years from now
and 20 years from now than we are
currently and I did sell a house for 7
million I did not negotiate the 6% down
and I feel I got my money's worth and
then some and I'm cheap by Nature
so it is it is I'm careless about it I I
just I got my money's worth and uh so
let's move on to
Becky uh this question is for Warren and
ay it's from Jeff oyster as a Burkshire
and Tesla shareholder I would like to
hear your thoughts on the potential
Financial effects to Geico assuming Elon
Musk delivers on his fully autonomous
driving goal on Tesla's most recent
earnings call Elon said if you've got
its scale statistically significant
amount of data that shows conclusively
that the autonomous car has let's say
half the accident rate of a human driven
car I think that's difficult to ignore
ignore assuming Elon succeeds in
reducing accidents by 50% versus human
drivers wouldn't auto insurance rates
fall to reflect the reduced underwriting
risk thereby adversely impacting Geico's
revenues and float and perhaps margins
Too Well yeah if it if it if it
if well let's just take the extreme
example let's say there are only going
to be three accidents in the United
States next year for some crazy reason
that that uh uh anything that reduces uh
uh accidents is is going to reduce cost
but that that's been harder to do than
people have done before but obviously
but if it really happens uh the figures
will show it and our data will show it
and the prices will come down I
would there have been a lot of people
talk about doing that in the past I mean
General Motors used to be very big in
the insurance business and and when Uber
first started they they uh use some firm
which now is I think a jle confirmed
they're close to bankruptcy now aren't
they because of taking things on at the
wrong
prices is that true of y y yeah yeah it
it it Insurance always looks easier than
it is and it's so much fun because you
get the money at the start you know and
then you find out what they've done
something stupid later on but but in you
know it's it's it's it's a very tempting
business when somebody hands you money
and you hand them a little piece of
paper but uh really knowing whether
you're I mean if if accidents get
reduced 50% it's going to be good for
society and it's going to be bad for
insurance company's volume but but but
but you know good for society is is what
we're looking for so
far this you might find kind of
interesting I mean the the number of
people
killed per 100 million passenger
miles uh
driven uh I think it actually was the
when I was young it was like 15 but even
post World War II it only felt of like
seven or thereabouts and and Ralph nater
probably has done more for the American
Consumer than just about anybody in in
history because uh that seven or six is
now come down to under two and and I
don't think it would have come down that
way without
him uh there have been some kind of
fluke figures of what people did during
the pandemic which are quite interesting
because they they didn't drive
immediately they didn't drive as many
miles but they they drove more
dangerously didn't they is that right a
g y yeah so the point I want to make in
terms of Tesla and the fact that they
feel that because of their technology
the number of accidents do come down and
that is certainly Pro provable but I
think what needs to be factored in as
well is the the repair cost of each one
of these accidents has skyrocketed
so if you multiply the number of
accidents times the cost of each
accident I'm not sure uh that total
number has come down as much as Tesla
would like us to believe Tesla has been
toying with the idea of writing
Insurance directly or indirectly and so
far it hasn't really sort of been much
of a success time will tell but I think
uh you know automation just shifts a lot
of the expense from the operator to the
equipment
provider okay we're getting close to
noon when we're going to break for lunch
I just want
to tell everybody that I uh would
appreciate it very much if they will get
in their seats and be ready at at 1:00
when we reconvene because we will have
another very short we movie in we'll
just have a a little explanation of
something that I think will be of
interest certainly of interest to me but
it uh uh so I would like to we will
break promptly at 12: and I would like
everybody to uh uh really make an
attempt to be in their seat and
quiet at 1:00 and if you can't do that
if you'll wait a few minutes and watch
in the halls and all that but we will we
do not want to be seating people and
have people Milling here at 1:00 and
just like a play in New York or
something we'll it'll take a few minutes
and only a few minutes to cover what
we're going to it at uh at 1:00 but uh
we don't want to
be uh seating people during that period
but now now let's uh we'll go on till
12:00 and then have a break until
1:00 and uh we will go to station
11 my name is Humphrey Lou and I am from
Charlottesville
Virginia I asked a question last year
and wish to pose it again it can be
considered a
followup there is something to be said
for
traditions it is the same question but
it is a changing and world we are
in looking at Global Trends it
increasingly does seem that zero
emission Vehicles may have finally
reached the cusp of massive
adoption do you see any opportunities in
this space either in specific vehicle
manufacturers or in related
Technologies as an addendum I will note
that Burkshire has very relevant
interests in energy Pilot Flying J and
byd thank you yeah well we will I hope
you're right
and uh massive adoption is has been sort
of a moving Target so far
but I hope we get there but Berkshire
would not
be I don't think that we bring any
special
talent to that
field uh you've got to be
manufacturers and uh uh I would
certainly not know how to pick the
winners in an industry like that but
I'll be delighted if there there are
some
winners uh but don't count on us for
seeing who the winners will be and don't
count on us for predicting when
something will
happen uh it obviously has been a moving
Target so far and and
uh it is an incredible problem that
Society faces and and
uh it it may be that
uh
that it may be that uh governments are
not very good at solving it for a while
it's it's uh uh all of climate change
is it's got a terrible problem just in
the fact that you know it affect the
that the United States particularly has
been the one that's caused the problem
the most and then we're asking poor
societies to say well you've got to
change the way you live because we lived
the way we did and uh
uh you know
that that really hasn't been settled yet
it uh uh you know it it it's a
fascinating problem to me but I don't
have anything to
add to how you really slice through the
world when I was born in 1930 there were
just essentially two billion people in
the
world uh population statistic now
there's 8 billion now if you'd asked
anybody in 1930 if you take the 50
smartest people in the world and you
said what's the op Optimum
population uh for the world when you're
93 years old they would have not said 8
billion there wouldn't be anybody have
been close to it but we did it now we're
reaping some of the consequences of
having having done that and uh we got
the benefits in the United States I'm
exaggerating here to some extent but the
developed World basically got it and
then we're telling a whole bunch of
other people that we want them to change
the way they live live because of the
way they live we we lived uh way they
lived
so we will see what happens with it but
uh that's that's a problem that that is
the very very very hard to sell that
solve uh among a couple hundred
countries and I really don't have
anything to be to be
uh uh to contribute on it and now I've
got instructions from the thing the the
the the monitor in front of me I would
like to introduce one person
here uh that uh uh
has you you all know because she's been
her so many times but um uh my friend
Carol
Lumis
who is now well she's going to be 95 on
June June 25th uh you can send
president's care of our office
uh and Carol has edited the burshire
annual
report since since
1977 right there we are
[Applause]
then and there
there are two points I'd like to
mention every year I give
Carol a uh little
um item for a bracelet that is a replica
of the front page of the report that
year and they're different colors and
all of that sort of thing and so she now
has what since
1977 what 47 of them and she I think
she's put 10 on each one but
uh I I I've always wondered you know if
she' put them all on
one one arm with one arm would now be
four or five Ines longer than the other
and but I'm sure she's she foresaw that
but I want to reveal one other I want to
reveal I well I want to ask one more
question uh while Carol was here
because uh I'm sure almost everybody in
this
audience grew up like I did uh knowing
that
tiops lifetime batting average was 367 I
mean he's the leader among everyone and
uh it may be that that record is never
broken and
taob 367
Immortal but
uh Carol
uh has a distinction that probably most
of you don't know
but uh she dated
Tai
and and
Carol
uh was was
officed at uh 6th
Avenue and uh in 50th Street in the time
life
building and NBC was right across the
street
Street in in uh Rockefeller
Center and the quiz shows became the
head of
TV and Carol being the kind of person
she is walked across the street at
lunchtime and went on the qu show of the
late
1950s and they gave her
the indust or they gave her the question
regarding
baseball and Carol answered them all
correctly of course she was encyclopedic
on all kinds of things but so she knew
all the
answers
and
she proceeded that she was single at the
time and she proceeded back to her
office at fortune and at some point she
got a phone
call
from sounded like a fairly young man in
Georgia and he said my uncle is Tai
cob and he would like to take you to
lunch at
21 and so Carol went to lunch with taob
at 21 and and I think he subsequently
had one more lunch and then she decided
to call it off uh
but those of you who follow baseball may
have noticed that in the 1990
they found that the statistics had been
faulty when T cob played and that he
actually only batted
366 uh that there were a couple of that
bats they didn't
count so the real
question I want to know with from Carol
and I think she should maybe tell us is
that would she have dated ta cob if she
not I mean I know she wouldn't have I
know she wouldn't have dated taob if his
batting average had been 300 or
something like that but where was the
cut off point at which she would have
told taob to stay in Atlanta and forget
about coming up to New York and if Carol
would if anybody has a microphone Carol
would care to express herself on on that
question it's the unanswered question
I've had in all inquiring minds have had
and uh uh uh only she knows the
answer and she's with her daughter she
married a wonderful guy John LS and
Barbara's Barbara's with her I'm I'm
sure Barbara's been always wanting to
ask this question but I've it it's it's
kind of tough when you're in the family
but I am I'm sort of an noxious guy old
do in front of a lot of people
Carol
zero or or we can have Barbara's guest
either one was she she would have been
happy to go either way right you would
have
gone thank you
Carol Carol Carol is the best business
writer she comes up the town of Cole
Camp Missouri you know I don't know
about say around a thousand probably she
never took an accounting course and she
ended up becoming the best business
riter in the United States
and uh uh we you know she didn't want to
be an editor actually I mean she could
have done other things at Fortune but
she just plain liked writing business
stories and like I say that uh nobody
came close to her and she started from
scratch uh but
uh in
1977 I asked her to edit my report
and she turned out to be just as the an
editor she was a
writer and
it uh all the way through this year
including this year Carol has edited the
Berkshire
report and uh to the extent anybody
enjoys reading them let's give a hand to
Carol
okay and I've been told to show a video
right before you go to lunch because
it's only 30 some seconds and then we'll
talk a little bit about more about it
when we come so if we'll uh dim the
lights we will we will have we showing
what a Bircher
shareholder
did uh uh when she sold us a billion
dollars worth of stock the other day and
you'll meet somebody that I as the
Opus I know she is the Prototype she may
have more zeros but she's the Prototype
of a good many burshire Highway
shareholders it'll be the first thing we
talk about when we come back but some of
you may have noticed whenever it was few
weeks back when Ruth
goddman gave $1 billion to Albert
Einstein to take care of all the
and Ruth doesn't like a lot of attention
drawn to herself but here's how they
felt at Albert Einstein when they
announced that Ruth Ruth godsman had
just made a decision to take care of of
all the all of the costs
of Education at Albert
Einstein and it's going to be in
perpetuity so let's just show the
film I'm happy to share with you that
starting in August this year the Albert
Einstein College of Medicine will be
tuition free
and that's why Charlie and I have had
such fun running bur sh
[Applause]
she transferred a billion dollars to
other people she Happ to do with
birkshire
stock and uh and you know they offered
the name rename the school after and
everything like that but she said
howbert Einstein that's that's a pretty
good name to start with so you there's
no ego involved in it know nothing she
just decided that that she'd
have 100 plus closer to 150 eventually
of
students be able to start out debt-free
and and uh proceed in
life and she did it happily and she did
it without somebody asking you know name
it you know put my name on four all four
sides of neon lights and I Salu
her so let's all have lunch and we'll
come back and talk a little bit more
about that thanks